I
wanted to thank
Yeah.
like
that. You need
Great. I didn't
You saw when you said, "What are you
doing?" I was like, "Damn."
Okay, folks. Um, I've been sending so
many emails and I'm juggling so many
dates that sometimes I screw up on on
your final. I want to be clear there.
Your final is on Monday, May
12th. And you can do it in person or
online, but online only if you're not
going to be in New York. Right? If
you're going to be in New York, I want
you to be in class taking the exam,
unless you talk to me and you have
something very specific, like a flight
leaving at 6:15 and you want to get it
done at the airport before you leave or
whatever. If you're going to be in New
York, I want you to be in class taking
the exam with everybody else. If you're
not going to be here, if you're
traveling somewhere else and you want to
take it online, it'll be the exact same
exam from 4:00 to 5:45 on Monday, May
12th. So basically the two choices just
in case you want to trap. So let's see
where we left off on any questions about
the logistics of the final exam. Yeah.
Distribution for the exam like the it's
the same exam. Should be same. Same
exam. So exact same exam. All you'll be
doing is doing it on a computer and
entering your stuff into the stuff. So
it's exact same exam. So it shouldn't be
the distribution should be any
different.
Yes. Question one question is everybody
here who's a person or do we have here
and other there will be another
classroom so there'll be two rooms
actually there might be three rooms
because the big rooms are taken so I
think you see 24 UC 25 and this will be
the three room for the people taking the
class so you'll be spread out like and
the thing is I've already gone through
the class in terms of rotation out of
this room so I'll have to be unfair and
somebody will get another room a second
time around whe I don't Whether it's a
good thing or a bad thing, nothing I can
do about it. So, you know, but there'll
be plenty of room in this room. Okay.
The reason I know I don't really want to
make it widespread online is especially
because Brightpace is not designed to
capture where you are and where you take
the exam. I'm concerned about I know
you're all honest. You would never do
stuff like this, but that you know
people who are not so honest. Um, so I
want to be make sure that if you're
taking it online that you're because
Brightpace can actually locate where you
are. So if you're in New York and you
claim not to be in New York, I will
know. So take it only if you're
traveling. Take the online version only
if you're traveling and you really can't
take it in person.
Well, then take it in person. Nobody's
forcing you to take it online, right?
Something like Bryce needs to track your
current location. Yeah, of course it'll
track your current location. How else
would I know if you're sitting next to
somebody and taking the exam as a
pair? So it it tracks your IP address
and once you track your IP address, the
rest kind of comes from
it. Okay. So um the final project is due
a week from today in cla you know after
class at 5:00. So and the numbers are
due by Sunday. So let's pick up where we
left off. We're talking about the option
to expand the option today. And there's
a third and final option I want to get
started on which is the option to
abandon. What am I talking about? Let's
suppose you take a really long-term
expensive project. It's a 30-year
project. You're taking it because you
think it's a good project. Is it
possible three, four, five years into
this project that you decide wasn't such
a great idea to begin with? It happened,
right? Wouldn't it be nice if you could
just walk away from those investments
rather than stay locked in into 27 more
years of bad cash flows? That's what the
option to abandon is. It's a put option.
It's the only real option that's a put
option where you abandon. When you
abandon you get a certain amount and you
abandon only if the present value of the
cash flows from continuing is less than
what you would get by abandoning it.
Sounds kind of abstract. So let me make
it a very specific
example. You've heard of Lear aircraft
makes little corporate jets. You of
course heard of Airbus. So I'm going to
play the role of Lear Aircraft and
you're going to be Airbus. So I come to
you with a joint venture
proposal. You ask me about open book
open notes. It's same rules as the quiz.
So it's open book, open
nodes. So I'm L aircraft. I come to you.
I want to create a joint venture. We're
going to create small commercial
aircraft and it's going to be a 50/50
joint venture. So I want you to put in
half a billion. I'll put in half a
billion. And then you ask me the key
question, which is what will the cash
flows look like? I give you the cash
flows. You work out the present value of
the expected cash flows. And it turns
out to be less than a half a billion.
It's 480 million. So in terms of NPV,
what does this project look like?
Negative net present value project. You
get ready to walk away, but I really,
really, really want you as my joint
venture partner to offer you a deal. I
said, look, if you become my joint
venture partner, I will give you the
right to abandon this project, walk away
from
it, and receive 400 million. Less than
the half a billion that you invested,
but I put a floor on how much you can
lose.
Let's see why this might tilt the
decision in favor of accepting this
project becoming a joint venture. Okay,
let me add some additional details.
Let's suppose that 480 million that I
got as a present value has a standard
deviation of variance and it's
uncertain. That variance is.16. The
project itself is a 30-year project, the
joint venture project. But I give you
the right to abandon for the next five
years. Why don't I give you the right to
abandon for the next 30 years?
No, it's more than that, right? Let's
suppose a project is a great project.
What do you do? You for the next 29
years and 364 days, you enjoy the cash
flows and the last day you show up and
say, "I never like this project. Could I
have 400 million back?" Right? So that's
why I had to cut it off after 5 years
because then the option to abandon has
to go away. Let's value the option to
abandon. The present value of the cash
flows from taking the pro take from the
project today is 480 million. What will
he get by abandoning it? 400 million.
It's a put option. So, it's an out
ofthe- money option. You would not
abandon it
today. Because this is a finite life
project. Every year you wait, the
project is going to get less valuable.
There's one less year of life. So, I'm
going to take off 130th of the cash
flows as a cost. The variance is.16 and
you get five years to exercise the
option. Let's see the magic of option
pricing valued as a put. The value that
I get is 73.23 million. The original NPV
was minus 20 meg. I've given you a put
option worth 73.23 million. Effectively,
you're going to be more likely to take
the project now with the option to bet
it. The only problem is I gave you this
option as Leo aircraft. I better have an
NPV that's big enough to cover that
value. Otherwise, I'm going to end up
with a negative NPV.
But the option to abandon basically
captures the fact that if you have the
flexibility to be able to walk away from
a project, you're more likely to take a
long-term project then you don't have
that
flexibility. So think of it again more
in more general terms. People especially
in the aftermath of COVID in 2020,
people talked about being adaptable and
being
flexible. And if you bend flexibility
enough, you can see it's an option
argument. Being more flexible allows you
to walk away from your mistakes if
things don't go well and add on to your
ws if they go well. So call options and
put options and that's effectively
what's making you a more valuable
company. So any questions about the
value of flexibility, the option to
abandon because we're going to build on
that value of flexibility in a different
context. People see other companies put
options like that all the time.
Especially if you let your salespeople
do the promising, they're going to give
away put options now until the cows come
home, right? Because they're going to
try to sell stuff and they're going to
say, "Oh, if you do this and you want to
back out, we'll give you the right." So,
make sure you restrain your salespeople
from going around offering put options
to people because they get paid
commission from sales. They said you can
bring that TV back anytime you want,
right? So, it is natural for sales
people to give put options. it al so you
have to have some kind of restraint to
keep it from getting out of
control. Let's talk about options and
capital structure. How many of you take
fixed income classes? Okay, fixed
income. I mean basically valuing a bond
should be simple, right? Coupons face
value. What makes bonds complex are the
special features you add onto them like
what? floating rate bonds where the
interest rate gets reset. Caps and
floors on your interest rates when when
you have interest rates that change.
Convertible bonds. Every one of those is
an example of an option added on to a
traditional bond. So option pricing in
fixed income usually takes a form of
valuing those options. Those are not the
options I want to talk about. I want to
talk about a different option that comes
up in the context of capital structure.
In your corporate finance class, do you
talk about optimal debt ratios?
Act like you did, even though you know
Tyler, what's what's your optimal debt
ratio for a company? Oh, no idea. No, I
Okay. What is it? 30 40%. Like this is
like a banker answer. Don't give that.
Right. If it's 30 to 40% for every
company, Chad GPT could do it for us.
Hopefully, it's not 30 to 40%.
whatever debt mix gives you the lowest
cost of capital. So in my my corporate
finance class that I'm teaching the
MBAs, this is two weeks ago, every one
of them had to compute an optimal debt
ratio for their company. And about 80%
of the companies in the class are
underleveled, which makes sense. You're
better to be underleveled than
overlevered. They have too little debt.
So I'm going to give you an argument
I've heard for why companies that are
underleveled might choose not to go to
their optimum. They say look we we don't
want to do this because we value
financial flexibility. Saying what does
that mean? Basically financial
flexibility captures the fact that if a
great project comes along you want to be
able to take that project and having
excess debt capacity allows you to do
it. And when I first used to hear this
argument would stop me because who's
going to argue against financial
flexibility? It sounds like a good
thing. So I want to dig a little deeper.
What is what does it mean when a company
says we value financial flexibility and
how would you value that
financial? So we're going to value
financial flexibility as an option. I'm
going to use an option pricing model,
but ignore the model itself because the
implications that come from looking at
financial flexibility as an option is
what I want you to take away from this
discussion.
So I'm going to go back to I think 1997.
I was um you know write writing my first
edition of my applied corporate finance
book. I was looking at Disney and coming
up with an optimal debt ratio for
Disney. It's been updated multiple times
since. And if you think about the fact
that you have companies with excess debt
capacity, let's first look at the payoff
diagram from thinking of financial
flexibility as an option. The strike
price here is what you would normally
need to reinvest in a typical year as a
percent of value. So 5% of my value, 4%.
So that's going to vary across
companies. So think of that as a strike
price. What's the value of having excess
debt capacity? You're now going to a be
able to take an investment that's much
bigger than your normal investment
drawing in excess debt debt capacity.
What happens if that never shows up?
What was the cost of being
underleveled? Your cost of capital is
higher than yourself and your company
value.
Exactly. You have a higher cost of
capital than you needed to have. That
becomes the cost of the option. I know
it's incredibly abstract, but hang in
there. This was my Disney calculation in
1997. Their current debt ratio was 18%.
At which point the cost to capital is
12.22%. I computed the cost to capital
at every debt ratio. You guys can have
the mechanism to be able to do that. How
do you get the cost of equity at every
debt ratio? What do you need to do?
Unlever the beta and then relev it at
every debt ratio. You say, "How the heck
am I going to get a cost of debt at
every debt ratio?" Computer synthetic
rating, interest coverage ratio. So,
it's actually a very simple process.
Their optimal debt ratio is 40% at which
point their cost to capital is
11.64%. They're at 18% debt. They should
be at 40%. So, let's say you make this
pitch to Disney. You guys have too
little debt. And Disney says, "We know,
but we're not going to borrow the money
because we value financial flexibility."
How much are they giving up by being
under 11? 58 basis points, right?
11.64 -
12.22%. If the value of financial
flexibility is greater than 58 basis
points, you're going to say, "Okay,
don't borrow the money. Financial
flexibility is worth too much to you.
I'm going to try to value financial
flexibility."
As I said, I'm going to stretch option
pricing models. So, as you look at it,
it's good to take it with a grain of
salt. Here's how I came up with the
inputs for the S in the model. I looked
at what a typical year brings in as
reinvestment needs. How do we define
reinvestment in in valuation? Net capex
change in working capital. I took that
every year. I took it as a percent
value. The average was 5.3% that became
the S in the model. That's what they
will typically face in a year as
reinvestment needs. For the variance, I
looked at the variance in that number
each year over the five years. So I
looked at the standard deviation of the
five years. The variance that I got was
375. So it's a not only is there a high
reinvestment need, but it varies across
time. For K, I looked at what they could
raise from internal financing from their
internal cash flows, whatever's left
over after taxes. So that became that
was the 4.8% that becomes the K and I
computed the value over one year because
I wanted to be able to compare it to
what I gave up by having a higher cost
of
capital. You plug in the numbers the
value that you get for financial
flexibility is
1.6092%. That's what the inputs for the
option. But remember the value of a
project comes from
what? That it can earn more than its
cost of capital. And that's going to
become a key part of the value of
flexibility. Because Disney has a
history of earning well above its cost
of capital. The value that I got for
flexibility was 085% of
that. How much did I give up being
underleveled? 0.58% of value. What did I
gain from
flexibility? 085%. At least in the case
of Disney, what does that mean? I'm
going to not push back. I'm going to say
look beyond under lever because for you
the value of financial flexibility is
greater than what you're giving up by
having a lower cost of capital. Yes,
Sophia strike
price in
the strike price is actually what you
can raise from internal funding. So if
you have a lot of money that you can
raise from internal funding the value of
the option gets lower, right? The S is
the typical reinvestment. So what you
get in a typical year over
time. So let's look at the implication
because this to me is the bigger part of
it. When you look at the value of
financial flexibility vary across
companies, the value of financial
flexibility should be greater for
capital constrained companies than
companies that can go raise external
capital whenever they want. Do you see
why?
If you can raise as much capital as you
want, why do you need to have excess
debt capacity and hold back on cash if
you can go out and raise capital?
Smaller companies should value financial
flexibility more than larger companies.
Emerging market companies should value
financial flexibility more than
developed market
companies. Companies in sectors that are
unable to access capital market should
value financial flexibility more than
companies that are able to access
capital. That's the first job.
Second, it depends on how unpredictable
your reinvestment needs are. If you go
back to that option pricing model,
remember that standard deviation in
reinvestment needs over time. If you're
in a business where you know exactly
what you will need to reinvest over the
next 10 years, you don't need financial
flexibility. You can go raise the
capital rate now set it aside. Companies
that don't know what the reinvestment
needs will be. There's a lot of
unpredictability reinvestment. You're a
tech company. Who knows how much AI
spending you will have to have next year
or two years from now will value
financial flexibility more than
companies in stable businesses. And
here's the third and final
factor. Remember how we divided
businesses into good businesses, neutral
businesses, and bad businesses. Good
businesses are businesses we can earn
well above your cost of capital. Neutral
businesses you struggle to make your
cost of capital and bad businesses you
earn less than your cost of capital. You
see how that enters the game? If you're
in a bad business or a neutral business,
don't even talk to me about financial
flexibility. It's worth nothing to you
because what are you going to do? Your
projects all have zero or negative net
present value. If you're in a good
business, you should value financial
flexibility a lot
more. As you get out there and you talk
to companies and they use the financial
flexibility argument, check them out.
test to see whether these are the kinds
of companies where financial flexibility
is worth enough that you're going to
allow them to be
underlevered because that underlever
allows them to maintain that
capacity. Any questions on flexibility
in
general which brings me to my final real
options example and this is the only one
that you can actually apply on your
project. Yes.
Yeah.
Are we assuming that the option to
access capital at a future point is more
valuable than having that capital today
already in cash? You know, in a sense,
we're assuming that option doesn't even
exist. In a sense, there's a normal
capacity to raise capital. If you have
to raise more than that, unless you have
excess debt capacity, you can't raise
it, which means you got to turn down the
project. That's what gives the option
value. That's why the more access there
is to external capital, the less value
there is to the option to maintain the
flexibility. That's why emerging market
companies value flexibility more because
they often don't have access to external
capital markets. So let's talk about the
final real options example and this is
the only one where you have a short of
applying on your project and as I
describe this see if it applies to your
to your company. When you think about
equity in a publicly traded company,
there are two features to equity that I
want to bring to the front. The first is
equity is a residual claim. What does
that mean? Residual claim, Jake.
Whatever's left over, you get whatever's
left over. So, in any given year, you
get whatever's left over after everybody
else has been paid. And if you liquidate
the company, you get whatever's left
over after you've paid the lenders.
Agree? The second is equity in a
publicly traded company has limited
liability. William, what does that mean?
Limited liability.
In other words, you pay $3 per share.
What's the lowest price your share can
go to? Zero. Right? Your broker can't
call you and say, "Your share is now
worth minus $6. Can you please send $6?"
Thank God for that. Right? Because you
own a private business. You have
unlimited liability often, which means
that your business can go to zero and
the banker can come after your personal
assets. That can't happen with a
publicly traded company. Residual claim
and limited liability. Let's see how
this plays out as an option. So, here's
what we're going to do. You guys are
going to be equity investors in the
company. You guys are going to be
lenders to a company. So, you get a
contractual claim. As equity investors,
here's how the payoff diagram looks. If
you liquidate the company, what are you
going to do? You're going to sell off
all the assets. You're going to take the
cash flows. You're going to pay the debt
off. And if there is any money left
over, you keep it as equity investors.
And if there isn't, then you said,
"Tough guys, limited liability." And you
walk away. What's the most you can lose?
Whatever you paid for the stock look
like a call option to you is right. I'm
going to take this very simplistic
framework and apply it to value and
option and extract some really powerful
features out of a very simplistic
example. So here's what the the
structure looks like. You have a company
that has assets worth a 100 million
right
now, but there's uncertainty about what
that value will look like in the future.
The standard deviation of that value is
40%. So it could go up to 130, 140, it
could drop to 60. This company has one
zero coupon bond with a face value of 80
million and 10 years to maturity. We'll
talk a little bit why I had to make it a
zero coupon bond. It makes my
optionality a little easier to buy. So
that's what those guys have. They have a
name 10 years zero coupon bond, $80
million at maturity. As equity
investors, can you liquidate the company
anytime you want? Yeah, you can get
together and say we're liquidating the
company. If you liquidated it today,
play out what'll happen. You sell the
assets, you get 100 million. You pay off
the debt. Remember, you got to pay the
face value of 80 million. You'd be left
with 20 million. you probably wouldn't
do it. Why? Because it's probably better
to run the company and see what happens,
right? So to complete the process, let's
suppose the 10-year bond rate is 10%.
I'm going to argue that with that very
minimalist information, you should be
able to tell me how much the equity in
this company is worth and what interest
rate you would charge on the debt. I
haven't given you any betas, cost of
capital, ratings. Here's how I'm going
to approach it. You're the equity
investors. You have a call option. The
underlying asset is the firm. It's worth
100 million. The exercise price. If you
liquidate the firm, you got to pay the
lenders. The 80 million becomes the
strike price of the option. How much
time do you have to play this game? 10
years. Now, do you see why I made it a
zero coupon bond? If a regular coupon
bond, how long do you get to play the
game before the lenders show up at your
door? You got a coupon every six months.
So, there's a series. It doesn't. The
option argument still applies, but you
have 20 options piled on top of each
other. I'm trying to keep my life
simple. So the next 9 years and 364
days, you run the company. You do
whatever you want to do, but at the end
of the 10th year, you got to pay the
lenders 80
million. The value of the firm itself
changes over time. So that's 04 squared
is.16. You have 10 years to play the
game and the riskless rate is 10%. I
have all the inputs I need to value
equity as a call option.
So here's the first thing I did. I'll
plug the numbers in. D1, D2, N of D1,
and N of
D2. Remind me again what N of D2
measures. Measures the probability of
something happening. What does it me?
Probability of paying the money. S being
greater than K. What's S here? The value
of the assets. K is the value of the
debt. So there is a 63% chance that the
value of the assets is going to be
greater than the value of the debt.
Which means there's a 37% chance of
what? What happens to the value of your
assets is less than the outstanding
debt. What do what do we call that in
finance? Bankrupt, right? There's a 37%
chance of bankruptcy. You file that
away. If you plug the numbers through
and you get the value of the call
option, you get 75.94 million. Say, what
does that measure? That's the value of
equity in the company treated as a call
option. If the equity is worth 75.94
million, the firm itself is worth 100.
The rest has to be debt. The value of
the debt is 24.06 million. It's a zero
coupon bond, right? How do zero coupon
bonds work? You pay $80 million 10 years
from now. If the value of that bond
today is 24.06 million, you can solve
for what interest rate you're paying.
The interest rate you're charging is
12.77% a year. 2.77% more than the
risk-free rate.
your default
spread. That 37% chance of failure
coming right out of the option pricing
model is a different way to think about
failure risk than the way we've thought
we so far we've used ratings to get
there. We this is a third way in which
you can get that default probability is
by using an option pricing model.
So let's say at this stage you believe
big mistake and you pay 75.94 million
for the equity the fair value right now
right given the value of the firm is 100
million let's say you wake up tomorrow
to a catastrophic
news your company has two factories one
in
Florida one in California take your
pickquake or
hurricane let's say it's a hurricane
your Florida factory is wiped
No insurance, the value of your firm
drops to 50 million. Is this good news
or bad news for you as equity,
Jake? Not a trick question. Bad news.
Unless you have a very perverse
definition of good news,
right? But I have a very simple
practical question. Remember the value
of your equity was 75.94 million
yesterday. I wiped out 50 million of
your value. My question is what will
happen to the value of your equity after
this bad news? You have three choices.
It'll drop by 50
million. It'll drop by less than 50
million. It'll drop by more than 50
million. You want to try what? What
should it be? I'm going to drop more
because at that
point we have like 40% variance like
that doesn't
even cover. Okay. So you think more than
50 million, right? You want to say
anybody want to agree Sophia?
is
yeah uh the company is now a stress
company and they I would assume that its
cost will increase but the value of the
firm drop when when you have when you
lose half your company what happens to
value of your firm it goes from 100 to
50 million
right so the 50 million is going to be
the effection
and if it drops by less than 50 million
somebody else has to bear the pain.
Who's who else is in this game? The debt
holders. In fact, let's play it out.
Let's see what happens. Right? Let's
play let's see the effect. The 100
million becomes 50 million in my model.
So, the value of the firm drops by half.
The K remains exactly what it was. I
still owe the 80 million. I still have
10 years. Technically 9 years and 364
days, but let's treat as 10 years. How
come the variance doesn't change?
because it's two factories, right? It's
a percentage change. So basically the
level has gone down. The variance stays
at.16 and the 10ear bond rate is still
10%. Remember what the value of equity
was 75.94. Let's see what it turns out
to be now. It's now 30.44 million. It
dropped by 45 12
million. Who else is bearing the pain?
The 24.06 has become 19.56 million. and
it's dropped by 4.5 million. My interest
rate and my debt obviously will now go
up because it's an $80 million zero
coupon bond. But let let's take a look
at what's changed the most. What was the
property bankruptcy before this
happened? And let's see. Let's look at
the numbers
here. It was 37% chance of bankruptcy,
right? Let's see what it is now.
the 58% chance of bankruptcy. Let So
three things happen. One is my
likelihood of bankruptcy went from 37%
to 58%. Sophia is right. The distress
has gone up. The value of my debt is
decreased. Why? Because the bonds are
much riskier. Now, the value of equity
has dropped, but not by the entire 50
million, but only 45 million because the
lenders stepped in and bore some of the
pain. Not because they wanted to, but
because I dragged them in.
Once I started on this, I couldn't stop
myself. Let me
explain. The value of the firm went from
100 to 50 million. The equity hung in
there, right? So, I dropped it to 40
million, then 30 million and 20 million.
I would kept dropping the value of the
firm. I wanted to see when equity would
become
worthless. And you know what? I couldn't
make it go away. Incredibly stubborn
instrument. I dropped the value of the
firm to 5 million. They still owe 80
million in debt, but the value of the
equity is still hung in
there. Samita, why do you think the
value of equity hangs in there? What is
it that's keeping equity alive here?
Even though the value of the firm has
become 5 million, they owe 80 million in
debt. The management's done such a
rotten job that you want to get them out
of there, right? So, they lower the
value of the firm. But what's how much
time do you have to play this
game? You have 10 years. It's time and
hope. Hope that something good will
happen. Then you pray that something
will happen. Most of the time nothing
good will happen. It's a deep out of the
money option. But basically, you're
buying it for the same reason you buy a
deep money option.
Gave me an entirely new perspective on
what it means to go
bankrupt. Actually, my daughter who done
30 gave me this perspective when she was
three years old. She's a financial
genius, I think. Not really, but I'll
give her the title. This was the summer
when I was playing Monopoly with my two
older
sons and she insisted on joining in.
Tiny little creature, but incredibly
persistent. So, we let her in. And after
two games, I had to ban her cuz she was
like a oneperson and roron. You know how
in Monopoly when you pass go you collect
200? She kept going into the bank and
collecting money for no reason at all.
She'd put hotels and properties that
didn't belong to her, start charging you
money. So finally I said, Kendra, you're
bad. She starts walking around say,
"You're bankrupt. You're bankrupt.
You're bankrupt." I'm very impressed
with a three-year-old using the word
bankrupt. I said, Kendra, what does the
word bankrupt mean? expecting an answer
like the value of your outstanding
assets is less than the value of
liabilities. She said bankrupt means you
don't get to play the game anymore. You
know what? What's keeping the value of
equity afloat here? You still get to
play the game. As long as you get to
play the game, you're not quite bankrupt
yet. That's what's keeping the equity
afloat. It's time and uncertainty. Two
things we worry about all the time in
finance are your allies
here. So distressed equity, when you buy
distressed equity, you're effectively
buying out of the money options. You
know what vulture
investing? What do vulture investors do?
They buy equity in deeply troubled
companies, often with a lot of debt.
You're saying, why would you do that?
It's the exact opposite of traditional
value investing, right? So they're
buying good companies that are safe.
They buy, you know, these troubled
companies that are on the verge of going
bankrupt. They buy a 100 of these
companies, they're buying a 100 out of
the money options. Most of the
companies, what's going to happen to the
value? Going to go to zero. But among
the companies that pay off, they make
enough money that they cover the losses
on the rest. Now, I'll give you an
example. Continental
Airlines, now United in 1993, traded at
a dollar per share, was on the verge of
bankruptcy. We bought it at a dollar per
share. Two years later, it's trading at
$53 per share because it made it back.
That's a
5,200% return, right? That's the kind of
return you make on deep out of the money
options. But that's what drives this
mindset. Any questions on treating
equity as a as an as an out of the money
option? Yes. Have a mechanical question
for you get value of debt by subracting
the value of the equity option. the
value of the firm. You're getting
interest rates treating as market value
of debt. That's basically market value
of debt. Everything in this is just
market value of
debt. Let's use this to kind of extract
a couple more
lessons. Let's assume you've taken go
let's go back to the pre-c catastrophe
value for the equity 70 I'm
sorry pre-catastrophe value 75.94
million for the equity 24.06 million for
the debt.
I'm a project salesperson. I show up at
your office and I'm client has a value
on a project. You ready? This project
has a negative net present value. What's
your in first instinct? Throw me out.
Right. I said, wait, wait. Not only does
it have a negative net present value, it
is a very risky
project. Yeah. Exactly. Right. So,
here's my question. Is it possible that
you could take a negative net present
value that's very risky?
Is it possible for equity to become more
valuable after you take a bad risky
project? Let's play it out, right? What
happens to value of the firm and I take
a negative net present value project? It
goes down by exactly 2 million. 100
million becomes 98 million. That's bad,
right? Strike price stays 80 million.
That's a face value of the debt. You
still have 10 years, but the variance in
firm value because I took a very risky
project went from 0.16 to 0.25. It's
become a less valuable, more risky
company. And I'm the equity
investor. Here's the magic. My value of
equity went up by about 2 million. But
who's the big loser in this process?
That land holds. You know what the
lesson I get from this is? If you're a
banker and you're lending money to a
distress company, you can never be a
passive lender. You know what a passive
lender is? You lend money and expect the
company to do the right thing. you're
going to get ripped
off if you're a lender to a distress
company. If you lend money, you better
take a role in how the company picks
projects, what it invests in because the
equity investors are playing an option
game. What makes the value of an option
greater? Higher risk. They're going to
take your money and risk it on bigger. I
mean, this is like going into a casino.
The first 15 minutes you lose all your
money. The casino lends you another
10,000. Are you going to play it really
carefully with the 10,000? No. you're
going to go for you're going to put it
all on one number and hope it pays off
because you're bankrupt anyway. It's
know effectively you're so far
underwater that you really don't care
except you want to get out of
there. When you're looking at distressed
companies, they're going to behave in
ways that are strange because the equity
investors running them are effectively
taking bigger and bigger risk because
that's the only way they can see
daylight.
One final example with this because it
kind of, you know, again pushes against
traditional views in finance. We're
going to talk about acquisitions right
after we finish real options. And one of
the rules in acquisitions is if you pay
fair value for an
acquisition, you're not going to be hurt
as an equity investor. So let's say you
are going to go out and the $100 million
company that we went back to. Let's say
you're back to that company. You're
going to go out and acquire another
company which has a fair value 150
million. You're paying exactly 150
million. What's the NPV of that
investor? Zero. Right? And we're told
that zero net present value investments
cannot hurt you as an equity investor.
Let's see if that's true. There's my
firm right now. $100 million. That's the
firm that I own that I have an equity
value of 75.94. There's a second firm
out there that I'm acquiring with $150
million value. It too has debt. They
both have
debt. What's going to happen after the
merger? I'm going to combine the two
firms. What happens to two
assets when you combine them? What
happens the standard deviation of a
portfolio of two assets when you combine
them? You remember it's B portfol it
shrinks. And what is it that makes it
trick? You lose the the covariance term,
right? Unless they're perfectly
correlated. So this is one of the first
things we start with portfolio theory.
You combine two assets. You combine two
companies, especially if they're in
different businesses, with correlation
less than one, in this case point4. The
combined company is less risky than the
two companies that went into the mix.
It's like magic. You're saying who gets
you combine the two companies. Let's
work out what the value of equity and
debt are in the combined company.
There's the value of equity in the
individual companies. There's the value
of equity in the combined company. If
you add up the values here in the
individual companies after the merger,
equity loses $3 million in value.
Lenders gain 3 million in value.
Intuitively, why is that happening?
Tyler, you want to try?
Okay. Go ahead, William. It's buying
from the customer.
It's safer, right? The interest rate as
lenders you said for the individual
companies was based on the riskiness of
those
companies. they've combined, they become
a safer company. You still keep the same
interest rates you had when they were
risky companies. You're going to benefit
as lenders. This is what happens in
conglomerate mergers is equity investors
will lose value as the company expands
if it doesn't do something to counter
this effect. So what are the two things
you can do as equity investors to claw
back some of the 3 million back from
lenders? Sophia
that's but that's yours anyway right so
you want to get the money back from the
lenders you want to so you want to claw
the 3 million back
one is or you can borrow money to do the
acquisition if you borrow money that's
one way to claw it back the other is to
go to the lender say guys this is a
safer company you either renegotiate and
give me lower interest rates or I'll pay
off all my debt and replace it with
cheaper per debt. Conglomerates have to
think about that actively because if
they don't, their equity investors will
lose value over time as they get bigger
and more diversified.
Yes,
this is part of it, but that's a
different issue that comes from the way
conglomerates get priced. Remember when
we talked about some of the parts, we
talked about some of the parts pricing
because you're getting the pricing from
pure group companies and conglomerates
often are badly run. There's a discount
on what you get on some of the the some
of the parts pricing. So that's what's
called the conglomerate discount. Yes.
Why does the value of equity not
increase as well?
Ah that's a good question. Why doesn't
the value of does anybody wonder? That's
a great question. When a company gets
safer, at least in the way we've thought
about risk, why doesn't the value of the
equity in the company go up when it gets
less risky? The investor always
remember how we compute cost of equity?
What do we use as our primary risk
metric? Costa. What does beta measure?
Only systematic risk. Because of that
there can be no benefits you get as an
equity investor from combining companies
in different businesses because the risk
that gets eliminated is not the
systematic risk. It's a company specific
risk. That's what the the correlation
measures. So the way we estimate cost of
equity there is no benefit to going out
and buying a safer firm or a riskier
firm to equity investors because the
only risk that's being priced in is the
risk you can't diversify away.
But you you see where it might be when
we combine two private firms that then I
think you can make the argument that
equity investors benefit. But that does
actually make sense. This is why
companies should never diversify for
their shareholders. Why? Because
shareholders can do it themselves
without paying a
premium. It's the one re it's the one
reason for acquisitions that really
doesn't carry any water.
So, let's talk about trying this on a
distressed company. How did any of you
have when you did your DCF end up with a
value for your company that was less
than the outstanding
debt? You had trouble getting the
somebody must have because there were
quite a few people who had trouble
getting I'll give you an example in my
MBA class. Somebody was valuing Weight
Watchers. Weight Watchers as you know is
in a lot of trouble. They did a DCF
value for the operating assets and the
value that they got was less than the
value of the outstanding debt. So from
an intrinsic value standpoint, what
would you conclude? The value of the
equity is zero. They tried pricing the
company with an enterprise value
multiple because the equity multiples
don't work. And every pricing they did
also gave them a pricing for the assets
that was less than the outstanding debt
of a pricing basis. The equity was worth
nothing.
You see why this might be their last
chance to get a value for the equity.
They're buying Weight Watchers for the
same reason you buy an out of the money
option. So, let's talk about getting
these numbers for a real company because
the example I gave you was highly made
up, right? I gave you the value of the
firm. There was only one zero coupon
bond outstanding. No, I gave you the
standard deviation the value. You need
all of that to actually try this on a
real company. So let's talk about how
you would get these inputs for a company
if in fact you had a trouble company.
Let's start at the value of the
firm. If you have assets that are
sellable, you have seven real estate
properties, you can take them up, add
them all up, and that could become your
S in the model. Right?
But if you're doing this after you've
done a discounted cash flow valuation,
there's a way in which you can use your
discounted cash flow valuation as your
starting point to get the S. Remember
how when you take the present value of
the free cash of the firm at the cost of
capital, you come up with the value of
the operating assets. You can make that
the S in your option pricing model if
you don't count the growth potential.
Basically, you're saying if I just have
assets in place, investments I've
already made, what would I pay for the
company? a DCF value can be your asset.
So if your assets can be liquidated, you
can add them all up. You can use that as
S or you can use a discounted cash flow
model to get started on this process.
For the variance, there are two ways you
can do it. The hard way and the easy
way. Let's do the hard way and get it
out of the way because I don't think any
of you want to take it if you don't have
to. If your company has both shares and
bonds traded, you can take the stock
price and the bond price, get the
standard deviations on both and compute
a standard deviation in firm value. I'll
give you an example with the the company
that I did, but it's messy. Why? Because
distress companies, the equity and the
debt start to behave in strange ways.
Here's the shortcut. Let's say you have
a distress steel
company. How do we get baiters for
companies? We did a bottom up beta,
right? Looking at other companies in the
business. What if I could give you a
bottomup variance in value where if you
tell me what business you're in, I can
give you the standard deviation in firm
value of other companies in that
business. You go to my web web page, I
actually have a data set of variances in
firm and equity value by
business. Much easier and actually much
cleaner to do. You just use that as your
standard deviation for the value of the
debt. Here's the reality. If you have a
distress company, you're not going to
have one nice zero coupon board. You're
going to have probably 10 different debt
issues with different maturities,
different interest
rates. I'm going to cheat. I'm going to
take those 10 different debt issues and
make them the equivalent of one big zero
coupon. So, I'm going to add up all of
the money you owe and act like it's the
face value. Take the weighted average of
the maturities or durations of your debt
and make that the duration of my zero
coupon bond. And I'm going to make my
example look very much like my
simplicity. I'm cheating all along. If
you're an option pricing purist, you're
probably going to freak out. But option
pricing purists will never get to the
end of actually getting a value for a
company because they're so caught up in
purity. So, let's try this out. You've
got a Euro tunnel. It's a hole in the
ground between England and France where
cash goes in but never comes out. was
originally built with this great idea of
you we're going to make a lot of money
but it never has made money. This was
actually an old valuation I did of Euro
Tunnel 1998. Let me set the stage to use
this distressed equity approach. You
need two things. One is you need to have
a money losing company where there's no
light at the end of the tunnel right
now. Second, you need a lot of debt.
That's why I said for most of you it's
not going to work. You can have one of
the or the other. Okay, so you have a
money losing company but it doesn't have
debt. Okay, or you have a company with a
lot of debt but it's not money losing.
You need both pieces to come together.
Let's see if Euro Tunnel fits both
requirements. In 1997, Euro Tunnel had
operating losses of 56 million pounds.
It's money losing and net losses of 685
million
pounds. Most recent year, its book value
of equity had become negative. Why?
because it had lost so much money over
such a long period that it was
underwater. It's a money losing company.
Check. Does it have a lot of debt? God,
does it have a lot of debt? It is 8.9
billion pounds of debt spread over
multiple debt issues. Remember what I
said I'm going to do? I'm going to cheat
and make it all look like one big zero
coupon bond. So, I'm going to take all
of the debt they have due treated that
as a face value of the zero coupon bond
and take a weighted average of the
duration of these debt
issues. The weighted average duration is
10.9 years. I'm going to take all of
their debt and act like they have one
big zero coupon bond with a face value
of 8.9 billion pounds in a maturity of
10.9 years. Starting to look a lot like
that simplistic example, right? What are
the two things I don't have yet? the
value for the firm and the variance in
that value. For the value of the firm, I
went back to my DCF roots. I did a
discounted cash flow valuation of Euro
Tunnels assets. I took the operating
income and I adjusted the margins over
time. Did all the things you're supposed
to do with the distress companies with
revenue growth and margins and
reinvestment. And the value for the firm
that I got was 2.3 billion
pounds. How much debt do they owe?
almost 9 billion pounds and this is my
upbeat optimistic valuation. The value
I'm getting is 2.3 billion pounds. Is
the company in trouble? Insane amount of
trouble. But the one I have two things
going for me. One is the debt is really
long-term. Remember the duration is 10.9
years. The other is the value itself.
The 2.3 billion pounds will vary across
time by how much. Here I actually used
the stock and bond prices that I was
able to get for Euro Tunnel. Euro Tunnel
stock price variance is about 41%. Its
bond price variance is about
17%. I'm looking at the firm value which
is both equity and debt. So I combined
the two 85% of Euro Tunnel's value came
from debt, 15% from equity. I took that
weighted average two asset portfolio
with the fact that the correlation in
stocks and bonds was only 0.5. The
variance in firm value is
0335. So I have 2.3 billion pounds in
value. The value is changing over time.
Point that becomes the variance I'm
going to use for the option pricing
model. I have pretty much everything I
need. The S in the model is the value
for the company 2.3 billion pounds for
my DCF model. So as we go along if you
have the money losing highly indebted
company check check off each box. You
can take your DCF value that becomes
yes. The K in the model becomes the
total value of the outstanding debt you
have short-term long-term all put
together. The life of the option becomes
the weighted average of the durations.
If you're in a hurry do maturities, it
really doesn't matter that much. 10.9
years. The variance is the variance
coming from the stock and the bond
prices. And the riskless rate is the
T-bond rate that corresponds to the life
of your option. With those inputs, I get
a value of D1 and D2. N of D1 and N of
D2. Clear? What's the probability of
bankruptcy for your
tunnel? What do we use? What's the
likelihood of bankruptcy?
For this one, what do we use? N of D2
is 0.0751. There's a 92 12% chance that
they will not make it. Why? The debt is
so high. But here's the miracle. You
have a company that's an absolute basket
case,
right? But the equity is still worth 122
million. Why? Because there's
uncertainty and time and you're hoping
that something good will happen. Sophia
companies
that would not go bankruptcy and leave a
normal company. For example, companies
that are likely to be bailed out,
companies that that's even better for
you as an equity investor. Remember,
every bailout lengthens the life of your
option. Euro is actually a classic
example where that would happen. Every
time a bank payment came due, the French
bank, the French government would put
pressure on the bank. the the it's a
British bank the the British government
would put pressure as an option as the
equity investor holding the option this
is great because it keeps lengthening
the life of your option and makes your
equity more valuable
adjust your bankruptcy such well
basically or the way it'll show up is
the 10.93 years will become 15 or 18 so
that's basically how it shows up is
you're extending the life of the option
you extend the life of the option the
value of equity will go
in there is a lot of like seven debt
companies in Europe that keep you know
being supported by bank because and
equity investors will benefit basically
it just means you have an extendable
option where the option never gets
exercised
yeah but it's not worth something but
make it longer you'll have to make just
to make a guess that it's longer
remember as you lengthen out to 20 25 30
years the optionality will basically
take over and push the value of your
equity
So you're giving the equity investors a
free play by doing
that. So let's summarize what we've
learned from real options. There are
options
everywhere. Most of them have no
significant economic value because they
lack
exclusivity with a key word. Do you are
you and you the only one to do? Now the
biggest advantage of using options is
they give you a mindset that allows you
to think about value in places where
traditional intrinsic value and pricing
don't work. Distressed equities, no
technologies that are not viable today.
What I want you to take away more than
the option pricing models is the mindset
that comes from thinking about something
as an
option. Any questions on real options?
There'll be one problem on real options
on the final exam, right? Nobody should
be allowed to graduate business school
without having worked through a black
Scholes model at least once in their
lifetime. And I'm going to make sure
that happens during this class so you
can get it out of the way. So every
final exam, the last problem will be an
option pricing problem. Work it through.
But basically what you think about is
that S, K, R, T, sigma, and some cases a
cost to delay and how it plays out in
your option
value. Uh about 15 years ago, I get a
call from a student of mine who started
running these training programs. So he
calls me and he says, "Look, I'm running
a training program in New York. Could
you would you be willing to come in and
talk to my trainees?" And I said,
"What's a training program on?" He said,
"It's a training program for CFOs of
serial
acquirers." Serial acquirers are
companies that do a lot of acquaintance,
CFOs of companies. I said, "Are you sure
you got the right guy?" Because you know
what I think about acquisitions, right?
And he said, "I know, but I want you to
come in and talk to these people because
for the rest of the day, they're going
to be hearing from M&A bankers." What do
M&A bankers think about acquisitions?
They're the mother's milk of all deals,
right? This is how you make money.
So I showed up and my cover slide kind
of gave away where I was coming from.
That acquires a novice, seven steps to
sobriety. Basically, I think of
acquisitions as an addiction. Start
doing it. You can't get out of it. So
let's talk a little bit about
acquisitions. And before I do that, are
there any of you who are planning to be
an M&A this summer as interns as you
know as your end game?
So along the way, I'm going to offer you
a deal. That's a seven-part test. And if
you fail more than two, I'd like you to
reconsider the M&A thing. I I think
you'll be okay. You know, enough. I
think you'll get all seven right. But
we'll do a seven-part test. If you're
ever planning to be an M&A, maybe this
is a seven-part test you should take.
Let's start with the bad
news. Acquisitions
collectively destroy value for
acquirers. Let me back this up. This is
actually from a bunch of different
studies averaging out what happens
around the acquisition day. So day zero
is the day the acquisition is announced
to the acquiring company's stock price
and to the target company's stock
price. So the red line is the target
company's stock price. What happens on
the acquisition day? Stock price jumps.
What's interesting is what happens in
the days leading up to the acquisition
day. So there's day zero. It seems to
drift down, right? which either suggests
a very
know forwardlooking market or a more
cynical answer would be that somebody's
leaking information and trading on it.
For whatever reason, target company
shareholders clearly win. No target
company shareholder ever complains about
M&A. It's amazing for you. What about
acquiring company shareholders? No.
Little blip and then they decrease. This
is It doesn't look like they lose very
much, right? But here's the reason why
those two numbers can't be directly
compared. Acquiring companies are much
larger than target companies. A 2% drop
in the acquiring
company would be equal to about a 30%
jump in the target company. Collectively
on the acquisition day at least when the
market anoints winners and losers.
Target company shareholders are the
winners. Acquiring company shareholders
generally tend to be the losers. In 55%
of all acquisition announcements,
acquiring companies stock prices drop
when they announce the acquisition. So
what's the market
say? We don't think this acquisition is
a good
idea. But what do managers say when you
show them this? They say, "Well, the
markets don't see what we see." Which is
what you have the forecast of synergy.
They look
amazing. It's true. They managers do
have access to more information. So
there are studies that look at what that
look at what happens after the
acquisition date. So they track
acquisitions three, five, 10 years after
the merger to see if in fact the promise
of the deal is delivered in earnings and
cash flows and growth because that's
what was promised early
on. McKenzie's been doing these studies
over the last 40 years and they ask two
very basic questions. One is does the
return on capital and acquisitions
exceed the cost of capital? Sound
unfamiliar? We asked it of every other
investment. Why shouldn't we ask it of
acquisitions? Second, does an
acquisition allow a company to do better
against its peer group than before?
Because that that's a big sales pitch,
right? If you acquire companies, then
we'll do better than our peer group.
Most mergers fail both
tests. The McKenzie studies are pretty
negative. KPMG did a study in the late
90s where they focus on just one thing,
synergy.
many mergers. That's a big selling
point. They looked at what percentage of
deals actually deliver
synergies. You know what percentage of
deals actually delivers? About 17%. In
83% of all deals, there's either no
synergy or reverse synergy. What is
reverse
synergy? Two companies come together,
the combined company becomes less
valuable than the two companies going
into the deal. It's very perverse.
And there's no learning built into the
process. What does that mean? You track
merges over time. It doesn't look like
we've learned anything over 40 years.
Even though these results keep coming
back to us that deals for the most part
or M&A for the most part doesn't create
that.
Yes. Does this data change at
all? If you look at private equity owned
uh companies that do roll out private
equity don't do merges, right? They do
acquisition. So basically it's a
standard the difference is mergers is
you have two public companies come
together private equity deals you can
look at private equity investors and
whether they make money on acquisitions
and the answer there is it's changed
over time early on private equity used
to create value today at best you're a
neutral value creator in rollup scenario
so they have platform
and what's different there when you do a
rollup what's the difference between
that and and a typical acquisition deal
is much larger and also you when rollups
you often buy private businesses and you
roll them up that might be one place in
acquisitions where you can create value.
Why? Because you don't start with the
market price and pay a premium on top of
it. Now this much of this research has
been US focused because this is where
you have the most data. But here's some
bad news. The disease is spreading. Let
me explain what I mean by that. until
about 20 25 years ago. If you're an
emerging market company, usually the
target of
acquisitions. The last 20 years though
the worm has turned. Now you have Indian
companies buying UK companies, Chinese
companies buying US
companies. And when Indian companies
acquired, this is actually from a study
of Indian company acquisition. So these
are Indian company acquiring company
stock prices. There's the date of the
acquisition and it looks like at least
initially people are very positive but
then about three four five months after
the deal it's hangover kicks in and by
the time you get to 12 months 13 months
14 months you get the same phenomena
with Indian companies that you do this
is a problem across the world it's a
problem with acquiring companies paying
too much and markets waking up and
saying that was too much so if I were to
summarize What we've learned from
looking at acquisitions over 50 years is
that acquiring companies tend to pay too
much for target companies. They
overestimate the value of synergy, at
least at the time they do these deals,
and have a really difficult time
delivering on their
promises. But what's troublesome is
there's, as I said, there's no learning
to the process, which tells me that
there's something about the process
that's broken. And we talked about that,
right? What's the problem with the M&A
process? If you were to to have one line
that you could say this is what's wrong
with the M&A process, what's the big
problem?
Yes.
Which means
priorities, the priorities the deal
makers are the deal
analysts. You know what? Do you see what
I mean by that? Who makes a deal? The
bankers who analyze the deal? the same
bankers. It's a conflict of interest and
it's at the heart of this entire
process. So, I'm going to take you
through a very simple process of looking
at M&A and I'm going to point to seven
mistakes I see repeatedly made in M&A
deals. And let's look at why these are
mistakes. I'm going to start with what I
call risk transfers where an acquiring
company that's safe looks at a target
company and thinks it can make the
target company safe because it's safe.
We'll see how this plays out in
acquisitions. Second is what I call debt
subsidization where an acquiring company
has access to cheap debt and it uses
that debt to do an acquisition and
pushes up the value of a target
company. Third, and this should be
familiar by now, is that 20% control
premium has wre havoc in acquisitions.
saying, "But isn't control worth money?"
It is, but this is no way to do it. You
can't attach a 20% value to every target
company. Fourth, I want to take an
honest look at synonym. What exactly is
synergy? How do you value it? And how do
you make sure you get a share of that
synergy if you're an acquiring company,
right? Because if you're creating
synergy, you want to get some of it for
your
shareholders. Fifth, I want to talk
about pricing in the context of
acquisitions.
many acquisitions. The way you price
target companies in my view is
extraordinarily biased statistically and
we'll talk about where those biases come
from. Six, and this I think is the core
of the whole problem. In most M&A deals,
the decision to do something is made
first and then the deal analysis
follows. Who makes a decision? Somebody
way up at the top, the CEO, the top
management. You're the grunt who's
grinding out the numbers. Guess what?
They want to see confirmation that
whatever they've decided to do is in
fact the right thing to do. And finally,
what troubles me most about
acquisitions, there's no
accountability. If you make a $1 million
mistake in a company on a on a capital
budgeting project, you get fired. You
make a hundred billion dollar mistake on
an acquisition, you get
promoted. I don't understand this
process. So, let's dig a little deeper.
And I'm going to use a very simple
example to illustrate it. I want you to
keep this page with you. And I I'm going
to pass you through a series of tests.
And I want you to be honest with me
about whether you're passing the test.
You don't have to show me the page. You
can go fix it if you want and make it
look all right. Now, I'm going to pass
you through each of the tests. So, let's
start the process. You're going to be an
acquiring company. I'm going to be a
banker trying to sell you a target
company. And what's my job? To get you
to pay more. Right? So let's start with
a very simple target company. The target
company which is revenues of 100
million, operating income of 20 million
and after tax operating income of 12
million. Let's keep it simple. Let's
assume this company is company which is
going to deliver 12 million every year
in perpetuity. Zero growth for
equity. This company's all equity funded
with a cost of equity of 20%. What's the
value of this target? Yes. I think 60
million. 60 million. Tell me why you
were, you know, because I didn't give
you cash flow information. So why were
you able to get the cash flows? What is
it about this company? There is no debt
and you and I'm assuming that working
capital is not going to change. No,
there's something else I gave you which
requires you not to
investment there's no reinvestment. So
net capex is zero. Working capital is
zero. And because it's zero, 12 million
in after tax operating income becomes 12
million in cash flows. 20% cost of
equity becomes 20% costly capital. 12
million divided by 02 gives me 60
million. What's my job? I have to try to
convince you to pay more than 60
million. And that's what the tests are
going to take because I'm going to come
to you with a pitch and you tell me
whether you buy into the pitch. Here's
the first one. You're the acquiring
company. You're a nice safe business.
Your cost of equity is
10%. You see where I'm going to go,
right? I show you the target company, 12
million in cash
flow. And if your cost of capital is
only 10% or your cost of equity is only
10%, how much should you be willing to
pay for this company? 120 million.
Sophia, would you pay the 120 million?
No. Still,
you are so difficult. Could I say in
response to the speech that by buying
into this very very risky project I made
myself more risky so I should pay less?
You don't have to buy it. That's common
sense right? If you take a risky the
first rule in capital budgeting is the
discount rate for a project should
reflect the risk of the project.
Would I sell for 50? No, that's you
don't have to, right? Because a 60 is
fair value with the risk built in. So
you shouldn't be using your cost of
equity to to value a target company even
though it's your money. You know half of
all M&A valuations I see see acquiring
companies cost to capital used to value
the target company and I blame us in
finance for calling it cost to capital
because when you hear the word cost of
capital what do you think of it's a cost
of raising money but in a cost of
capital in a valuation is an opportunity
cost given the risk of what you're
discounting back. So the right discount
rate here to use is not the cost of
equity the acquiring company. It stays
the cost of equity of the target
company. Which means that I can't make a
risky business saves just because I'm a
safe
company. And if I insist on using my
cost of equity as the acquiring company,
guess what I'm going to end up doing?
I'm going to start buying risky company
after risky company because it'll all
look cheap to me because I'm using my
low cost of equity. So, first rule is
don't, you know, don't use your cost of
equity because if you do that, you're
going to end up overvaluing target
company. So, you guys were too good for
me on that one. So, that didn't work.
Let me try a different ploy. Let's
suppose as the acquiring company, you
have access to cheap
debt. You're AAA rate and you can borrow
money at 4%. and you also have excess
debt capacity and you choose to fund
this acquisition with 50% debt and 50%
equity. Let's forget about levering and
unlevering mus. Let's leave the cost of
equity at
20%. Let's work out the cost of capital
for this acquisition. 50% from debt at
4%, 50% from equity at 20%. My cost of
capital is going to end up at 12%.
Right? 12 million divided by 12% is 100
million. Sounds a little more
reasonable, right? You It's your debt.
You have cheap debt. Would you be
willing to pay 100 million? Why not?
Still doesn't change the fact that the
risk of the cash flows I received
another company.
But you have an extra 40 million you got
by using cheap debt, right? I could
raise that money to fund with other
project. There's a simple reason why you
don't want to pay the extra 40 million.
That 40 million has nothing to do with
the target company shareholders. If you
pay it as a premium, think of what you
paid for. You spent a century becoming a
nice safe company with a AAA rating and
you have excess debt capacity. You used
to pay a premium for a target company.
You're rewarding a target company
shareholders for something that they had
zero role in
creating. You know how often in
acquisition valuation you get caught up
in how the target company is being
funded? Because that's what we're taught
to do in cost of capital. Look at the
weights. When you look at valuing target
companies, don't look at the actual
funding because I can buy a target
company entirely with debt. I've seen
people use the cost of debt as a cost to
capital because they use 100% debt. You
can't do that because if it's not the
target company's debt capacity that's
being used to borrow money, it's your
debt
capacity. So, you're still stuck at 60
million. I'm getting a little desperate.
So, I pull out this control premium
thing. Everybody does this. Everybody
pays a 20%. So 20% of 60 million is 12
million. Shouldn't you be willing to pay
control premium when you buy a target
company or why not?
But is there a good reason for paying a
control premium? If so, what would that
reason be?
No. No. Desperate doesn't make it a good
reason, right? What is the essence of
control is you get to run the target
company instead of the existing
management. Are there things you might
change in the way the target company's
run
inefficiently or maybe it doesn't borrow
enough money. This is a place where you
can come in and say hey there is value
of control. But to value the control
what do I have to do? I have to value
the company twice. Once with the
existing management in place and once
with you in place and assuming it's a
badly managed, badly run company,
control could be worth 10%, 50%, 80%.
But it can't just be a 20% premium. It's
got to be company specific. So if
there's a lesson here, don't pay for
buzzwords. Control is a nice sounding
word, but you got to dig a little
deeper. Control of what? And how do I
come up with that
value? because otherwise you're just
paying 20% for something that might not
be there. It's the it proposition.
Remember we said if it doesn't affect
the cash flows and it doesn't affect
risk. We're we're trying to be explicit
about what control is
what. But that didn't work either,
right? So let me try the magic word
synergy. Let me set up first and this is
a question I think we've already
answered. Often you hear bankers say by
combining two companies we've become
safer. Therefore we should have an
increase in value for the equity. And as
we said that argument doesn't fly
because if you do your cost of capital
right and these are both publicly traded
companies combining the two companies
cannot create value by itself because
you're looking at only the risk you
can't diversify.
But could there be synergy in the form
of higher growth or lower cost in the
combined company?
Yeah. Theory at least. Let's say there
is higher growth and lower cost and you
value that
synergy. Should he pay that synergy as a
premium in the
acquisition? Tyler, I mean the the
dayto-day said that 80% did not have
synergy. But let's say there is synergy,
right? Let's say there's 50 million in
synergy. Should you pay the 50 million
as a premium?
It already includes the cost. If you do
pay it as a premium, what have you
effectively done? Who gets the benefits
of the
synergy? The target company share.
What's the essence of synergy? Two
companies contribute to creating it. If
you give it all away to the target
company shareholders, you have nothing
left for your own shareholders. Right?
So if there is synergy, not only do you
have to value it, you have to think
about how do I negotiate to get a share
of that synergy for my shareholders
because they did the dirty work of
actually combining the two firms. I mean
every step of the way I'm going to come
back to the price you're paying and
trying to negotiate for a share for your
shareholders. Yes.
cost which you then just want to sort of
make out of the journey like any other
cash flow right so in fact I'm going to
set up a framework for synergy is the
last thing for today there are two forms
for synergy one is called operating
synergy operating synergy is usually the
synergy that shows up in your cash flows
can take the form of economies of scale
or lower costs easiest form of synergy
to value or higher growth higher growth
how maybe you can take more projects as
a combined firm maybe you can earn a
higher return on capital as a combined
firm. Maybe you can earn excess returns
for a longer period as a combined firm.
All of which are arguments for operating
cash flows. I would love to tell you
that the bulk of the synergies in M&A
come from operating synergies, but they
don't. The bulk of synergy in most M&A
comes from financial synergy. And the
most common financial synergy is the
synergy you should never talk about if
it's a reason for your margin. You know
what I'm talking about? Taxes. If you're
doing a merger because you want to save
on taxes, for God's sake, talk about
everything but
taxes. Talk about strategic reasons.
Talk about real options. Don't talk
about taxes. Why not? Because the minute
you say this merger is motivated by
taxes, it's like waving a red flag in
front of the tax guy saying come and get
me and he or she
will. Taxes can be a reason for mergers.
Combining two firms can give you higher
depreciation. Maybe you have a
money-making firm, buying a money losing
firm. But as I said, don't mention if
that's a reason, keep it below the
surface. Talk about everything else.
Maybe combining two firms can give you
more debt
capacity. It shows up as a lower cost of
capital. In the case of two private
firms, combining two firms can actually
make you more valuable through what
metric? What's the discount rate we use
for private firms? a total beta, right?
What drives a total beta? The
correlation with the market. If by
combining two firms, I increase that
correlation with the market. I lower the
total beta. I can increase that. So on
Wednesday, we will pick up and talk more
about synergies and then kind of
complete the process and M&A. I will see
you on
Wednesday.
Professor increase the correlation.